i
[Música]
en eeuu los capitolios de las
principales ciudades se encuentran en
alerta máxima ante las advertencias del
fbi y sobre nuevas protestas lideradas
por seguidores del presidente saliente
de donald trump 15.000 efectivos de la
guardia nacional fueron desplegados en
washington para garantizar la seguridad
en la posesión del presidente electo joe
biden el próximo 20
el equipo de científicos enviados por la
organización mundial de la salud ya se
encuentra en luján con el objetivo de
estudiar el origen de el coronavirus
esto cuando el país reportó su primera
muerte por el virus en ocho meses
y túnez conmemora 10 años de la salida
del poder del presidente ben alí tras
intensas manifestaciones su dimisión
hizo parte de una serie de caídas
dictatoriales que recibieron el nombre
de primavera árabe pero muchos tunecinos
aseguran que las promesas de una vida
mejor no se materializaron
bienvenidos a una nueva tarde de
información de américa latina y del
mundo aquí en tras 24 mi nombre es
liliana valencia iniciamos en eeuu donde
las redes legislativas de las
principales ciudades del país se
encuentran en alerta máxima después de
que el fbi advirtiera sobre la
planificación de protestas armadas en
washington y las 50 capitales a
propósito de la posesión del presidente
electo joe biden el próximo 20 de enero
hay temor ante posibles nuevos actos de
violencia por parte de seguidores del
mandatario saliente donald trump
similares a los que tuvieron lugar el
pasado 6 de enero en el capitolio de
washington y dejaron cinco personas
muertas los edificios parlamentarios
están inusualmente custodiados por
efectivos de la guardia nacional que
despegó 15.000 soldados solo en las
capitales del país
entretanto se convirtió en el primer
presidente de eeuu en ser sometido a dos
impeachment dos veces a un juicio
político ya se aprobó en la cámara de
representantes la realización de
justamente un juicio político por
incitar a la insurrección y ahora se
espera la votación en el senado que se
reunirá la próxima semana sin embargo no
está claro cómo se desarrollará el resto
del proceso teniendo en cuenta que trump
saldrá de la casa blanca' en sólo seis
días
los demócratas de la cámara pueden
elegir cuándo enviar su resolución de
acusación al senado el líder de la
mayoría demócrata de la cámara de
representantes steny hoyer dice que
tiene la esperanza de que esté sea
enviado pronto una vez recibido la
cámara alta debe comenzar un juicio sin
retraso sin embargo el senado controlado
por los republicanos está en periodo de
receso hasta el 19 de enero es decir un
día antes de que yo bailen asuma el
poder y el líder de la mayoría del
senado mitch mcconnell dice que no
volverá a convocar sesiones antes de esa
fecha así que el juicio del senado no
empezará hasta que don action vaya
dejado el cargo el presidente de la
corte suprema presidirá el juicio nueve
fiscales nombrados por la presidenta de
la cámara nancy pelosi serán encargados
de procesar el caso camps aún no ha
comunicado cómo se compondrá su equipo
de defensa una vez que el juicio termine
se necesita una mayoría de dos tercios
de los senadores para condenar a
traidores para entonces será demasiado
tarde y para hoy seguir lo de su cargo
pero otros castigos podrían ser votados
parece ilógico que se puede impugnar y
destituir a alguien si ya no está en el
cargo la destitución parece ser el
principal objetivo de la impugnación sin
embargo mirando la historia existe lo
que yo llamo una impugnación tardía
incluso después de haber dejado el cargo
existe la posibilidad de que lo condenen
por el recurso de descalificación
si el senado condena podría en efecto
decidir hacer una votación posterior
para descalificarlo en futuros cargos
políticos y ese voto sólo requiere una
mayoría simple para ser aprobado por
ahora algunos senadores republicanos en
ruptura con sanz han dicho que
considerarán el artículo de acusación en
su contra pero al menos 17 republicanos
tendrían que unirse a los demócratas
para alcanzar el umbral necesario de dos
tercios para condenarlo haciendo que la
sentencia sea poco probable
un equipo de expertos de la organización
mundial de la salud aterrizó este jueves
en la ciudad china de wuhan llegaron una
semana más tarde de lo previsto debido a
complicaciones con el gobierno de
beijing y sin dos de sus integrantes que
se quedaron en singapur al dar positivo
por kobe 19
el objetivo es investigar sobre los
orígenes de la enfermedad justo cuando
se reportó el primer deceso por el virus
en 8 meses en el país varias ardillas
nos cuenta más
casi un año después desde el anuncio del
primer caso de kobe 19 en la ciudad
china de wuhan el origen del nuevo virus
aún es desconocido qué animal transmitió
el coronavirus a los humanos o cuánto
tiempo lleva el patógeno circulando son
algunas de las incógnitas sin resolver
ahora un equipo de investigación de
expertos de la organización mundial de
la salud intentará dar respuesta desde
la zona cero de la pandemia en wuhan
stories
todos los estudios deberían ayudarnos a
retroceder en la historia y en el tiempo
al año pasado e identificar áreas zonas
geográficas y un momento en el tiempo en
el que el virus pasó a la población
humana
podría ser un viaje muy largo antes de
que tengamos una comprensión completa de
lo que pasó en juega tenso la misión
tendrá dos fases y correrá a cargo de
diez expertos chinos y diez
internacionales epidemiólogos biólogos
expertos en la salud pública y zoólogos
para cubrir todas las ramas del estudio
dos de los científicos internacionales
no pudieron entrar al país tras detectar
los anticuerpos en las pruebas de kobe
19 mientras que en la estigmatizada
wuhan reciben la visita con optimismo
en primer lugar les doy la bienvenida
esperamos que dejen claro de dónde vino
el virus y que después de eso den a
conocer una conclusión veraz
weiser el equipo inicia su trabajo sobre
el terreno cuando las autoridades chinas
informaron de la primera muerte por
corona virus desde mayo así como la
imposición de nuevos bloqueos a millones
de personas de la provincia nororiental
a la vez que beijing impulsó una campaña
para vacunar a más de 50 millones de
personas antes de las festividades del
año nuevo lunar en febrero vamos ahora a
francia donde el gobierno anunció una
nueva ampliación del toque de queda
nacional desde este sábado la
restricción iniciará a las seis de la
tarde según lo anunció el primer
ministro jan castex esto después de que
los casos porque el 19 siguiera en
aumento y la norma se mantendrá por dos
semanas más en el país galo
y se cumplen 10 años de la salida del
poder del expresidente tunecino ben alí
estás intensas manifestaciones
ciudadanas que pedían su dimisión el
caso de túnez es considerado como el más
exitoso de la llamada primavera árabe
pero muchos ciudadanos consideran que
las promesas de una vida mejor nunca se
cumplieron
no mucho ha cambiado durante la última
década en este barrio de catherine esta
localidad cerca de la frontera con
argelia fue uno de los epicentros de la
revolución tunecina aquí fueron
asesinados varios manifestantes y para
esta familia que perdió un hijo amargura
no se va
al comienzo en enero no se escucharon y
estudiaron nuestro caso pero luego se
olvidó fueron los dos hijos los que
trajeron la libertad a este país la
gente está orgullosa de ellos pero sus
padres a ellos nos hicieron a un lado se
lo debemos a nuestros hijos darles
justicia
mi hijo mohamed murió hace 10 años pero
para mí se siente como si hubiera sido
ayer estas calles pueden ser nuevas pero
muchos de los problemas estructurales
tras esa expresión de ira de 2011
permanecen las ong aseguran que nunca se
materializó una esperada lucha contra la
corrupción pero para abbas en sage
algunas cosas mejoraron y hoy hay cosas
positivas como la libertad de expresión
la libertad para hacer campañas y formar
asociaciones pero catherine sigue siendo
uno de los pueblos más pobres y
marginales y eso es responsabilidad de
la sucesión de gobiernos
a 50 km de este pueblo una carretera nos
lleva a esta aislada localidad desde la
revolución estas montañas han sido
escenario de violencia entre las fuerzas
de seguridad y grupos yihadistas en
diciembre el sobrino de mustafa fue
asesinado los extremistas
sospechaban que ese joven pastor era un
informante nada ver su cara igual este
era nuestro hogar y luego los
terroristas vinieron y lo tomaron
bojanic esa es la casa de mi hermano
miren no siquiera tiene electricidad
miren cómo vive mi madre mi hija no
tiene dónde dormir
catherine tiene muchos mártires de la
revolución y hay hambre en el campo
diez años después de la revolución los
más vulnerables aquí se enfrentan a una
nueva amenaza la pandemia de covite 19
las restricciones supone que nuestra
falla no puede dar entretenimiento en
las bodas así que por ahora su música es
más que nunca una herramienta de placer
pero no para ganarse la vida
así finalizamos ustedes pueden continuar
con más entradas 24 punto com
[Música]